this is what the russian authorities
insist is not happening the russian
leader is adamant his military is not
hitting homes in the ukrainian capital
or elsewhere because attacking civilians
is an international war crime and
president putin insists he's doing
everything he can to preserve the lives
of civilians
that's in direct contradiction to the
evidence we and many others are finding
on the ground
in the center is a playground around it
are residential blocks people's homes
schools
they've been pretty much reduced to
rubble
and these are some of those who used to
live in them they've lost everything
it's not human to do this she says
to attack the children
they grab whatever they can in plastic
bags
pets tvs this is all they have now
right next door there are two schools
one is a kindergarten schools have been
suspended for the time being in the
capital or these classrooms would have
been full of pupils
[Applause]
these attacks are killing and they're
not soldiers or fighters this was an
elderly man one of many who felt too
frail to leave the city despite the
dangers
the daily attacks have left others badly
hurt
he survived with terrible head wounds
his wife did not
the victims here don't have much faith
in any peace talk succeeding and no one
we spoke to had any doubt about who the
attacks are aimed at
and you think it was specifically
targeted at civilians like you
why though
yes yes i definitely think this she says
putin's trying to kill as many
ukrainians as he
can and the kiev mayor is absolutely
certain these repeated attacks on
civilians are ruthlessly executed
do you think there's any mistake this
could have been a mistake or was this
deliberately targeting civilians uh okay
if we're talking about mistake
his mistake
last
morning was a mistake 24 hours ago two
days ago was mistake
huge mistake destroyed the harketh and
mariupol how many mistakes they do it
how many cities have to kill and after
that to explain about mistake
from from russian forces
the uns warned the country's food supply
system is falling apart they were
scrambling to save stocks here
a number of these shops have been hit as
well and impacted and that is the worry
that a lot of these food supply chains
bakeries food factories have all been
impacted as well and they're being
specifically targeted
so they're wasting no time pooling
supplies in kiev these are all donations
they're trying to make sure those left
homeless and hungry by the bombings are
somehow looked after
and this despite worries that food
warehouses in the country are running
low those who have are giving to those
who don't i think
that we are the second front
on this country because the army is the
first one volunteers and it was
second
this is true community whilst the
capital may so far have been spared a
major assault among the workers here
there are those who've also lost their
homes to the daily bombings like tatiana
back two days later helping those she
feels are less fortunate it's strange
it's like
something unbelievable it's like from
the movie something from the movie came
in my real life
she showed us her flat now in bits she's
moved in with friends for me i don't
think
that i can die or something like this
i'm afraid
i think
what i can do for
other people
and
somebody is right
how i can help
no because i'm lucky and in my building
about 400 apartments
and everybody alive
and other
i know other people not so lucky
the suffering is unrelenting and whilst
kiev defenses are so far holding the
capital's residents are still bracing
themselves for more of this and worse
alex crawford sky news keeve